An empty plaza outside Damascus Gate...
...shows just how different this Ramadan will be because of coronavirus.
It's usually crowded with shoppers buying food and new clothes for the holiday.
And the Al-Aqsa Mosque, Islam's third holiest site,...
...which is usually filled with thousands of holiday worshipers, is also nearly deserted.
Muslim clerics say people must stay home to stop the spread of the virus.
With corona, the situation has changed.
The Muslim religious authorities said, "Pray at home to preserve human life...
...because people are more important than anything,...
...more than the Kaaba in Mecca, more than the Al-Aqsa than anything.
Those places will still be there,...
...but if a person dies, that is permanent."
He added that Islamic practices like washing before prayer...
...can help protect against corona.
Ramadan traditionally features large family gatherings,...
...so social distancing is especially difficult during this time.
But public health groups and doctors warn it's essential.
The scarcity of pre-holiday shoppers in the Arab neighborhoods of Jerusalem...
...shows that the coronavirus is taking an economic toll.
Ramadan is going to be difficult this year.
We don't have work and we don't have money.
I have six grandchildren.
I want to buy them toys and new clothes for the holiday,...
...but I haven't had any work in two months.
Everyone is supposed to just stay home.
It's a little sad.
But religious leaders say the real meaning of Ramadan...
...is saving lives and getting closer to God.
Linda Gradstein for VOA News, Jerusalem.